stewart the monoa polar expedition
bernadette behaving like howard's mom
if you're a big bang theory fan you know
these storylines and probably despise
them
those and more coming up
leonard cheating on penny was completely
out of character given how innocent and
devoted he has been shown to be in his
affection toward her throughout the
series it was just a kiss why would you
even tell her because i didn't want
there to be any secrets between us as
much as the show played into geeky
tropes like the nerd falling head over
heels for the popular girl there was
something wholesome about leonard's
interest in penny and fans couldn't help
but root for them this is part of the
reason it felt so cheap to keep stalling
the relationship just to keep fans on
the hook
whether this manipulation was real or
imagined fans resented the various side
steps one of fan's least favorite
diversions was leonard's relationship
with stephanie although there was some
opportunity here to explore leonard's
chemistry with an outside character it
seemed rushed both as it began and as it
ended
the two hook up almost immediately after
meeting each other then after leonard
asks her to move out via text she's
never heard from again distractions
aside leonard and penny had the
potential to be and at many times were a
really sweet couple with a great love
story but they were dealt a tough hand
by the writers who in the pursuit of
introducing obstacles and keeping things
interesting often ended up missing the
point by having leonard confess that
after all those diversions he also
cheated on her while he was traveling
for work the show's writers only
cheapened the love story more
stewart's misery is simply used as a gag
without real character development and
as much as he wants to gain the
acceptance of the gang the writers
seemed to decide that he was much
funnier in depression the poor guy
became hard to watch after a while as he
never really changed in any substantive
way audiences loved him for the
well-meaning goofy outcast he was but it
never seemed like the writers or the
core characters agreed instead stewart
was milked for all the awkward sympathy
he was worth but really only enjoyed
cursory storylines
case in point the actor kevin sussman
who played stuart was upgraded to a main
cast member during the seasons howard
was away in space and raj desperately
needed someone to hang out with when
howard returned sussman was downgraded
to a recurring character once again
whether comedic or tragic the character
simply existed to fill out a lineup
while the group obviously has its ups
downs and petty squabbles over fixations
only nerds would dwell on the monopolar
expedition episode really makes the guys
seem like horrible friends who didn't
even like each other
this is a bit confusing considering that
the entire show is based around their
friendship the episode starts off with
everyone getting excited at the prospect
of essentially getting rid of sheldon
for three months after his grant to go
to the magnetic north pole is approved
when he suggests that the three of them
come along they are extremely resistant
to spending three months with quote an
anal nut bag howard even goes as far as
to say that this kind of scenario could
be the one that flips the switch and
turns him into the guy who goes crazy
and kills sheldon
and all that happens before they even
make it to the pole
raj is probably the most dateable guy on
the show one who actually wants a family
and is loyal and kind often being too
sweet and emotional too fast is what
damages his relationships when he
suffers selective muteness penny
introduces him to emily who seems like a
perfect match because she's deaf but she
seems to help him open up a little too
much as he basically tells her he loves
her immediately only to find out later
that she's using him for his family's
money
even when the series teases a romantic
interest for raj it rarely lasts as yet
another example what happened to yvette
the vet
she sort of disappeared so what was the
point in introducing her in the first
place
raj is perhaps the greatest victim of
the show's sacrifice of personal
development and happiness for the sake
of weak plots and gags one of rosh's
main relationships more successful than
most in the pitiful context of his love
life is the one with anu although this
partnering ends up feeling forced and
dragged out even the couple themselves
acknowledges that there's no romance
tries to create some fails and gives up
the writers seem to have given up on
raja's love life long
before throughout the series we watch
amy being spurned time and again in
terms of intimacy with sheldon these
awkward encounters were used for comedy
as a running gag but in real life it
would be incredibly hurtful for a woman
to be constantly denied affection and
intimacy especially as prolonged as the
situation was whether sheldon means to
or not he's actually subjecting amy to a
lot of emotional turmoil and worst of
all her plight pretty much exists for us
to laugh at the lack of intimacy almost
certainly feeds into some degree of
insecurity in the relationship
tv tropes often inflate gender
stereotypes for comedic effect which
results in characters especially women
being taken advantage of for the sake of
a joke
seeing a nerdy girl questing so
desperately for love is quite easy for
audiences to make fun of which only adds
insult to injury
this entire arc of bernadette basically
becoming howard's mother develops
essentially for the sake of a joke since
howard has a famously weird relationship
with his mom
where are you going to the toilet is
that okay with you but it doesn't honor
bernadette's character whatsoever and is
also kind of unsavory to watch one of
the first things the two bond over is
the fact that they both have overbearing
mothers instead of growing together from
their pasts both of them return to the
toxic roles they understand plus it's a
little creepy to hear howard say
bernadette is sexy when she's angry
while we as the audience are
uncomfortably aware of how similar
bernadette is to howard's mother when
she's enraged
even entertaining the pairing of raj and
penny is enough to make a lot of fans
cringe there are some lines in every
show that you just don't cross and some
characters you just don't pair up
seeing raj wake up in bed with penny
crossed that line
it was later revealed that they hadn't
done the deed and that this moment was
basically used for shock value as a
cliffhanger at the end of a particularly
important episode still fans weren't
impressed at all
and the twist meant that the writers
didn't even have to commit to their
decision which almost made it worse they
led fans on with a polarizing choice
that then turned out to be a red herring
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite sitcoms are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you